and it's a case more than a year in the
making this video is showing former
Raider Henry rugs accused of driving
under the influence and driving more
than 150 miles an hour killing a woman
and her dog in a fiery car crash rugs
and his attorneys telling a judge
they've agreed to a deal and that could
put him in prison for up to 10 years new
at six eight news now investigator David
Charles reports from court with the
evidence that you have not seen
Henry rugs and his attorneys here in
court telling a judge they've accepted a
deal that could put the former Raider in
prison from three years to as many as
10. 24 year old Henry roggs is accused
of driving impaired and killing
23-year-old Tina tintor and her dog in
this November 2021 crash prosecutors say
rugs was driving 156 miles an hour in
the 45 Zone with a blood alcohol level
twice the legal limit this video 8 is
now obtained after the crash shows that
car flash by in an instant documents the
eight news now investigators obtained
reveal officers found rugs wasn't
wearing a seat belt a witness finding
him quote hanging out of the car there's
a young man who has never been in
trouble before rugs first faced several
felonies appearing here in a wheelchair
during his first court appearance the
plea deal announced Tuesday reducing
that to one account of felony DUI
causing death and one misdemeanor charge
of vehicular manslaughter the eight
who's now invest obtaining these
documents were an officer talking to
rugs shortly after the crash says rugs
told him he was quote on his way home
from home the 8 news now investigators
also obtaining this 450 dollar receipt
from Topgolf where rug's girlfriend said
she and rugs spent part of their night
the receipt included in court evidence
shows the four guests shared 20 drinks
in other court documents prosecutors
write rug's girlfriend ordered two for
herself but did not know how many if any
drinks rugs had consumed did you notify
house arrest that you had a new
telephone number over the past 18 months
rugs who is free on bail appeared in
court several times as his lawyers
questioned blood evidence and asked for
new judges one judge ordering him to
wear an alcohol monitoring bracelet and
not to drive conditions allowing rugs to
practice at a facility but not leave the
state in a statement rug's attorney
saying this is the first step toward a
fair resolution to this matter and we
look forward to closure for all parties
involved rugs will be back here in court
next week to formally accept that plea
then there will be a sentencing
scheduled and it will be up to a judge
where to put rugs in that three to ten
year range outside the Regional Justice
Center in downtown Las Vegas I'm David
Charles 8 News Now